the movie opens with a narrative
discussing the potential existence of
life on other planets despite various
efforts to find extraterrestrial beings
conclusive evidence has not been found
as a result any discoveries in this
field can be a big milestone in human
history unless you sing for a punk band
in which case no one will believe you in
the next scene a spacecraft called
mellin is seen orbiting Earth inside it
Commander Roger Nelson communicates with
NASA Mission Control reporting
interference and the onboard monitors
the officer on the other end reassures
him explaining that they're in the
process of downloading an AI plug-in as
they Converse Nelson says he'll wake up
on Titan Saturn's largest moon a year
and a half from the current moment with
Control Systems already the control
center reminds Nelson that the
gravitational push will begin in 2
minutes and asks if he is ready for
stasis however the commander is busy
admiring the mesmerizing view of space
through the port hole just just so
godamn beautiful he eventually lies down
on a pod to go into hibernation for 18
months the scene then shifts to 2 and
1/2 years earlier where Nelson and his
wife Abigail are having some fun time
with friends amidst this Nelson receives
a call from a NASA officer informing him
of a space mission briefing tomorrow
this news doubles the couple's happiness
as Nelson is finally going to fulfill
his dream of going into space the next
day at the briefing NASA project manager
Gerald Becker tells Nelson that they
detected a radio anomaly a low frequency
pulse with regular repetition after the
first anomalous signal they detected two
more of it with higher frequencies
Gerald notes that these sound messages
create a perfect major tonal Triad and
concludes that the signal is artificial
this Revelation leaves Nelson in shock
because you can't believe that something
from the other side of the Galaxy is
sending a song to the earth when he
inquires about the origin of these
mysterious signals Gerald reveals that
all signals emanate from within the
solar system the first from Titan the
second from Neptune's moon called Triton
and the third from a dwarf planet ays to
gather more information NASA plans to
send Nelson into space the US Secretary
of Defense Craig Stewart provides
further details explaining that Nelson's
Mission involves visiting these
locations finding signal sources and
collecting samples sounds about as
boring as Starfield according to Gerald
the ideal window for the launch of the
spaceship will be only after 8 years but
there's also a less favorable one which
can be launched in 2 and A2 to prevent
China from taking the lead they must go
with the less ideal window the most
difficult part of this mission is that
Nelson has to spend 10 years in space
away from friends and family despite
this Nelson makes a brave decision and
volunteers to go later he shares the
details of his mission with his wife
Abigail is clearly upset because she has
to stay away from him for such a long
period initially she is is reluctant to
let him go but Nelson somehow manages to
persuade her better space than jail
honey no it's not yeah you're right the
scene then shifts to the 542nd day of
the mission which is when Nelson wakes
up from stasis he is greeted by his AI
assistant Ferdinand who helps him in
monitoring the spaceship systems this AI
voice provides a detailed report on the
events that transpired while Nelson was
asleep mystery recapped here you've been
asleep it also reveals that they are
going to enter Saturn's orbit within the
next 24 hours following this Nelson
starts checking the emails he received
from NASA control center among numerous
emails he finds video footage of his
wife who greets him and asks him to play
chess with her after responding with his
move Nelson continues reviewing the
emails from one of them he learns that
China has postponed their launch by a
year opting to head directly to Triton a
while later Nelson receives another
video message from Gerald congratulating
him on his progress in space Gerald also
tells him that he offered Abigail to
congratulate him in person but she's
undergoing a difficult time due to a
nervous breakdown despite feeling
saddened by this news Nelson continues
his duties as mellin enters Saturn's
orbit Nelson learns that the mysterious
signal originates near one of Titan
methane lakes with this information in
hand he boards a landing module and
separates from the main ship to approach
Titan's surface accompanied by another
AI voice named Neil he lands on a
glacier and then deploys a hose into the
lake to collect samples after this he
carries the necessary equipment and
Ventures to locate the source of the
signal upon reaching a bit further Neil
relays ferdinand's message to the
commander warning of an approaching
storm from the East and the potential
danger of methane fumes exploding
however Nelson being much closer to The
Source decides to retrieve the
transmitter before heading back my wife
used to Dutch oven me on the regular I
can handle a little methane soon after
he discovers that the signal source is
coming from the methane Lake despite
being aware of the risks Nelson proceeds
into the lake and locates the
transmitter resembling a glass ball he
retrieves it and hurries back to the
Lander just before the storm hits him
while waiting for the storm to pass
Nelson examines the alien transmitter
driven by curiosity he removes his
gloves and proceeds to touch it with his
finger disregarding Neil's warning as
soon as he makes contact his
communication with Neil is abruptly cut
off and he experiences the sensation of
being drawn into a black hole
fortunately when he panics and drops the
transmitter he regains normaly as the
storm clears Nelson makes his way back
to the Mother Ship once inside mellin he
sets his trajectory to Neptune heading
for another Journey he then immediately
contacts NASA control center and reports
about his Discovery shortly after Gerald
responds commending Nelson for his
outstanding work he also emphasizes the
importance of adhering to protocol and
avoiding any tampering with the object
hearing this the commander sends another
message admitting that he has already
touched the transmitter with his bare
hands and details its peculiar reaction
he requests permission to repeat the
action and record the phenomena on
camera while awaiting Gerald's response
Nelson examines the methane liquid from
the lake and is astonished to find amino
acids which indicates that life is
possible on the planet just then he
receives a video message from Abigail
who informs him about a big problem that
has arisen she claims that some Chinese
hacker hacked into her computer system
and tried to access information about
their current mission in order to ensure
safety Craig has threatened to
completely ban her from the NASA control
center as a result of this Abigail is
disheartened as she fears losing the
only way to communicate with her husband
although it's only been a year and a
half she already feels that she's
sending messages to a dead man in
response Nelson sends her another video
message urging her to stay strong and
wait for him he also tells his next
chess move wax is poetic about all of
those happy Dutch ofen memories and then
goes for stasis the scene then fast
forwards to 32 months later when Nelson
once again wakes up as before Ferdinand
greets him and starts reporting
everything that happened in his absence
you've been sleeping again watch out and
take care according to the AI an anomaly
was detected in the alien transmitter
coinciding with increased brain activity
in Nelson a phenomenon deemed impossible
during stasis while reviewing emails
Nelson comes across Gerald's video
message in which he discloses that the
alien transmitter is still emitting
signals resembling a binary code and
they're trying to decipher it another
email informs Nelson of an interference
in ferdinand's system probably due to a
hacking attempt later he again decides
to make contact with the alien
transmitter this time asking Ferdinand
to film it upon touching it the glass
ball illuminates and inexplicable images
Flash before his eyes making him feel
uneasy Ferdinand then transmits the
recorded video to the control center in
the meantime time mellin enters Triton's
orbit as Nelson reads the landing module
he receives another message from Gerald
revealing about a mishap in the Chinese
space mission that has resulted in the
demise of all three astronauts this
makes the commander feel nervous but he
continues with his mission the stakes
are higher this time as he must find the
second transmitter in a limited time or
else he'll miss the window to Aries the
next scene shows Nelson having landed on
Triton and searching for the signal
Source in a crater he cautiously had
down and manages to locate the source
within a few minutes turns out that the
transmitter looks exactly the same as
the previous one with only 9 minutes
before takeoff he stores the transmitter
into a container and starts heading back
to the Lander but in an unfortunate turn
he accidentally drops the container
while ascending this prompts Nelson to
go back to retrieve it despite having
only 4 minutes until departure he
manages to reach the Lander mere seconds
before the time limit he then instructs
Neil to initiate the engine and return
to the Mother Ship without any delay he
sets another trajectory to ays
afterwards Nelson sends a video message
to the control center updating them on
the second transmitter following this he
begins to examine the ice he collected
from Triton in the midst of this a video
message from Abigail arrives expressing
her deep longing as it's now been 4
years she further expresses her fear of
losing him especially after learning
about the tragic Chinese incident this
obviously saddens Nelson but he somehow
manages to Destro ract himself
continuing his analysis of the ice he
discovers several impurities unlike
those found in seawater later on he
receives a message from Craig who tells
him about how delicate the mission has
become to ensure safety Nelson will be
contacting only him whereas Abigail and
other civilians aren't permitted access
to the control center henceforth Craig
also orders Nelson to steer clear of the
mysterious transmitters due to their
unknown nature and potential danger but
despite the stern warning Nelson decides
to touch both transmitters
simultaneously as a consequence he under
goes another episode of inexplicable
Visions this is how I feel when I try to
spend time on Tik Tok the scene then
cuts to the
279th day of the mission and we see
angelan land successfully on ays there
Nelson finds the third transmitter but
this time it's covered with mucus upon
retrieving the transmitter and some
samples he heads back to the Lander
during the docking process with the
mother ship and faces a problem the AI
begins communicating in Chinese sensing
a looming threat he promptly orders
Ferdinand to wipe all of its memory and
review the security system thankfully
the situation is brought under control
enabling the module to dock successfully
as soon as he enters mellin Nelson
instructs both Ferdinand and Neil not to
authorize any system alterations without
his express permission following this he
begins examining the sample from ays
with ferdinand's assistance he discovers
DNA particles in it leaving him shocked
for a moment he records an excited video
message unveiling this most exciting
Discovery to the NASA control center in
addition he informs Craig about the
issues in ferdinand's system and asks
him to check the firewall until then he
decides to take full control of the
spaceship 4 hours pass by but Nelson
receives no response from the control
center while waiting he places the three
spherical transmitters side by side and
begins touching all of them just
fondling them in random orders and
gasping with Glee at one point he puts
all three of them together leading to
Visions with greater detail than before
soon after these Visions are abruptly
interrupted by deafening sound signals
Ferdinand reports a massive stream of
radio signals several million messages
passing through the spaceship's
communication system Nelson once again
combining the transmitters instructs the
AI to analyze the signals the analysis
reveals an endless stream of radio
Transmissions originating from different
points in the galaxy Galaxy the signals
are transmitted at the same time but it
remains uncertain whether this occurs in
real time or whether it originates from
a certain point in the distant past
Nelson tries to comprehend the
perplexing information he believes that
these signals were transmitted by
creatures similar to humans he then
theorizes that these aliens use quantum
entanglement to transmit signals into
radio waves eager to unravel more about
these signals he directs Ferdinand to
analyze a thousand of them in detail on
doing so the AI finds out that the
binary data within the signals is
encoded in the DNA code just then
Ferdinand detects another signal
emanating from the UR Cloud situated far
beyond the explored reaches of the solar
system it would take 38 years to reach
the signal Source if mellin continues to
operate it's at this point when Nelson
realizes that he can't back off after
coming this far after this he records a
final message to his wife revealing his
decision to fly to the ort Cloud he
apologizes to her for the difficult
years of waiting but he claims that the
signals are calling him and he can't
ignore it the art cloud is the ultimate
Dutch oven he then makes his final chess
move before ending the video Nelson then
instructs Ferdinand to set the
trajectory to the ort Cloud NASA as well
as the Department of Defense are against
such a decision by the commander Gerald
attempts to persuade Nelson to come home
and demands that mellin be returned back
to the center however our hero has
already made up his mind the movie ends
as Nelson sets his course towards the
new Mission labeling it as Mission day
one subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching